amy is with us in Chattanooga
hi Amy Merry Christmas I mean are you
better than I deserve what's up in your
world not much my husband and I are
currently on baby step number two good
and I guess we probably feel a good bit
of responsibility for our parents we
both lost our fathers at a young age and
my mother doesn't handle her finances
very well neither does my sister and a
few more of our family members and of
course when they turn to us and they are
looking for money in tons of needs they
you know they come straight to us and
ask for it and it's hard to say no we're
currently you know trying to focus on
our own debt and get get those things
paid off but we've you know been very
open about our success with you know
Dave Ramsey and saving up our you know
emergency fund and they know it's there
if they know that we have that thousand
dollars in our savings it's if something
was to happen they can always turn to us
and ask for it
no is not working anymore they just
don't accept it they you know say
there's a lot of things going on and
they use my nieces and nephews as an
excuse which breaks my heart and of
course I want to see those you know my
kids my nephew's having you know food on
the table you know sometimes they say
they don't have money for groceries and
we make we have the least income out of
all of everybody in our family it's info
so let's stop a song let's stop saying
it you're talking about mainly about
your sister let's just start with her
okay yeah she may make more money than
you and they don't them away feed their
kids so that's just a dormant stop
that's just asinine yeah it's just
ridiculous and then has the unmitigated
gall to ask you for money and she makes
more than you do and then has and worse
than that she's a travel agent for guilt
trips baby it's gonna be your fault now
you're their mother stupid
I mean really so here's the thing here's
the thing what's happening is this what
the only thing that's going to help you
is you're gonna have to get you're gonna
have to learn to love her better you
don't love her well and you're just a
wimp and and what's happening is is the
reason you're wimp is you think that's
being nice it's not being nice you are
you are buying crystal meth from meth
addict you're buying her drugs that are
going to kill her you are participating
in her misbehavior you are not helping
her you are harming her you are an
enabler does that make sense when you
give her money when she doesn't handle
money well and she makes more money than
you that's the same thing as giving a
drunk a drink yeah absolutely
and so the the proper way to love her is
not make her happy on the short term
it's to help her win long term and how
is that gonna happen by you giving her
money no the way she's gonna win long
term is she decides she's gonna be a
grown-up and be responsible with the
money she has right that's when she's
gonna start winning and so here's how it
would sound at our house okay sis I love
those babies of yours and I love you and
I'll do anything in the world for you
except bring harm to you and
participating in your financial
irresponsibility is bringing harm to you
and I'm not gonna do it anymore
because I love I love you too much to
help you continue to be bad with money
y'all make - y'all make too much money
to be broke so here's what I am going to
okay I am going to give you $50 this
time this time this is the last time and
I'm gonna give you a class called
Financial Peace University to learn how
to handle money and if you do not go to
the class every single class and you do
not learn how to handle money do not
ever ask me for money again because I
will not give you any more under any
circumstances
I love you too much to buy your drugs
and you're gonna have to get there
because you're just a sweet person yeah
you're just a tender-hearted kind person
and and you you're gonna have to see
what you're doing is mean when you're
participating in with your sisters and
irresponsibility you're being mean to
her and we can extend the same
conversation to your mom and then
that'll help you kind of break through
the enable but you know and sometimes
people say well David's tough love no
that's just love yeah it's not tough
love it's like your kid you know you're
no kid doesn't want brush your teeth
honey you have to brush your teeth for
two reasons one is we don't wanna smell
your breath the second thing is if you
don't brush your teeth you're not gonna
have any you know and we love you too
much to not let you know well I don't
wanna brush my teeth I don't really care
you're gonna brush your teeth because
I'm gonna stand here until you do until
you learn to do it and until it becomes
a habit twice a day for the rest of your
dad-blame life and that way you have
teeth because teeth are handy they help
you get jobs and they help you get
married and they help you you know you
need teeth right and this is the same
kind of thing but does a baby is an
eight year old little boy I always want
to brush his teeth well I can promise
you one hundred percent of the time they
don't write you it's something you have
to make them do for their own good and
that's not tough love that's just love
that's being a good daddy a good mommy
that's all that is and that's all you're
doing here is being a good sister I
don't want you to be mean to your sister
I don't you I don't want you to raise
your voice I don't want you be unkind or
sarcastic I was a little bit sarcastic
picking out over there a minute ago to
try to give you a little strength okay
but but the truth is but the truth is
you just I just want you to sit down be
kind to her and gently but firmly just
like you would a a little baby you
wouldn't ever be mean to a little
four-year-old kid but you are gonna make
them do what they need to do behavior
wise in order to exist in this world all
right you're gonna behave in a
restaurant you're gonna sit here and
you're gonna say yes ma'am I know man
and you're gonna behave and because you
have to learn self-control little baby
and I love you I mean I got these little
grandbabies and there's five of them
under five which means when they're all
at the house and one of them is melting
down at all times right it's just all
you know but the wheat do we get mad I
don't know get madam they're mad some of
them have a little temper fit you know
spit flying out their head and all this
and you know but I'm still but papa Dave
is not gonna we'll play that I just I
love you and you're just gonna sit here
and you're gonna be kind and you're
gonna lower your voice a little bit and
we're gonna straighten up here you know
and and this night you can have a same
conversation with your sister and it be
a loving conversation but she's not
gonna like it in their school in January
and I told her I said you know this is I
can't help you anymore yeah I just you
know our budget is even tighter than
what it was and it's not your job to
help her she's a grown person yeah she's
got kids it's her job and they got more
money you got this is ridiculous and
your mama's no better I mean you're the
same situation your mother just
misbehaves all the time and has gotten
away with it probably since way back
when your daddy was alive yes and he
just he just took care of her none of
them knew how to budget and I was the
first one to take the steps to learn how
to budget you know you know that you
want to go to the gas station they put
ten dollars and I fill it up to the top
yeah if you want to invest in them you
can do that you know put them in the
class we'll help you I'll give you a
I'll give you a couple memberships if
you want to do it but I don't I'm not
you have to call Kelly back after you
have these conversations okay okay and
tell her I'll put you on hold you can
get you on connect get phone numbers and
everything off air phone numbers but but
you know and if they don't want to go I
don't get my membership right you don't
either but if they all go well I'll pay
for it and you and I can help them
together but but I'm not sending them
any money agree you know I've done this
show for 30 years and I've heard some
really sad stories here on the air and
I've never give
a single person here on the air money
right and I could have it could the
whole stinking Dave Ramsey show could
turn into a telethon you know but uh but
we're not doing that it's not what we do
we're gonna teach you how to fish we
don't get fish away and so and that's
what you need to do here the book is
called boundaries by dr. Henry cloud and
Miss Amy you need to read it it's a
wonderful book that will help you a lot
with what you're facing here boundaries
by dr. Henry cloud your family doesn't
have any and you're trying to put some
up